hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast decoding the mind using
brain machine interfaces turning thought
into action by Nicholas fotopolous i'm
susie valdez of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
excited to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning if you cannot
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button at the top right or the Q&A
button in the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Nicholas has a pet sockless dr.
Tatopoulos is currently a professor at
the university of chicago he is also the
chairman of the computational
neuroscience graduate program from 2008
to 2015 he is currently running a
laboratory with for graduate students 5
post doctoral students and several
technicians which is funded in part by
the National Institutes of Health from
January 1998 to December 2001 dr.
hattaras
was an assistant professor of research
in the department of neuroscience at
Brown University
he completed two postdoctoral research
fellowships one in the department of
neuroscience at Brown University and the
other in the computational neuroscience
program in the California Institute of
Technology dr. hats Oppel is completed
his bachelor's and physics from Williams
College in 1984 his master's in
psychology in 1991 and his doctorate in
cognitive science from Brown University
in 1992 in 2001 he co-founded a company
called cyber kinetics neuro Technology
systems which took the basic scientific
research he and his colleagues conducted
to develop neural prosthesis technology
to assist people with severe motor
disabilities his research focuses on the
neural basis of motor control and
learning he is investigating what
features of motor behavior arm
and how this information is represented
in the collective activity of neural in
Samba 'ls in the motor cortex he is also
interested in how these representations
change as motor learning occurs to
answer these questions electrical
discharge of mini motor choral neurons
is simultaneously recording using multi
electrode arrays and correlated with
motor behavior the encoding properties
of the individual murder cortical
neurons are being studied to determine
how these cells properties relate to
higher-order representations involving
groups of neurons the possibility that
changing the functional connectivity
among neurons may occur during motor
learning is also being explored I would
now like to turn this presentation over
to dr. Hatake olace Thank You Tracey
thank you for spending some time to
listen to my presentation I'm going to
be talking to you about brain machine
interfaces as they applied to motor
control but what I'd like to do first is
begin with a brief history of brain
machine interfaces or neural prosthesis
as they're sometimes referred to a
neural prosthesis are basically a
prosthetic that is an addition to the
brain or in other words an interface to
the brain to and enhance the brain
function through outside devices so let
me start with a brief history you can if
you really stretch it a bit consider the
the origins of brain machine interfaces
back to the Classical period of Greece a
command of Croton who was a scientist
philosopher living in Magna Grecia
a colony of Greece in now modern-day
Italy first postulated that the brain is
the organ of percept
so this was actually a radical thought
because at the time most civilizations
including the Greek civilization thought
that the organ of perception and thought
was the heart not the brain so whether
it's the Egyptians the Greeks the
Persians the Babylonians they all
thought it was the heart and and the
brain was considered to be sort of this
some people thought of it as almost like
a bone marrow because it sort of felt
and looked like bone marrow others
thought of it such as Aristotle as a
radiator that radiated heat but a
chameleon possibly that the brain was
the seat of perception and in most of
his writings or actually all of his
writings are no longer with us but other
authors near the time of a command
report on his writings and he discusses
one concept which is that and I'm just
gonna write a state this and it's in my
slide here and the eye obviously has
fire within for when one is struck with
fire flashes out now if you touch your
eye like this what you're going to
experience is a spot of light on the
opposite end of your eye you might want
to try that that's what's called a
pressure phosphine it's a phosphine is
just a spot of light and it's this is
induced by actually applying mechanical
pressure on your eye
well the phosphine is basically the
basis for prosthetics basal prosthetics
which I'll talk about in a moment to
help blind people so that's we're
talking 500 BC here in the late 1700s
Galvani in his experiments with animals
where he applied electrical current to
nerves and to muscles show that these
muscles will contract when electricity
was applied and he talked about this
notion of animal electricity that
the the body in the mind of animals
worked via so-called animal electricity
well we know now that that's the same
thing as any other kind of electricity
but that really is the basis sort of
more modern day basis of neural
prosthetics because it argues that we
can interface with the brain through
electricity but really you really need
to go to the 1960s to the real birth of
brain machine interfaces and a cochlear
implant as shown here is perhaps the
most successful implant brain machine
interface to date and it's been
implanted in thousands of individuals
with profound deafness and so the way
this system works is you have a
microphone sitting outside your head and
then signals from the microphone travel
down through a cable to a set of
electrodes that are implanted in the
cochlea which is shown I'll show that to
you right here it's this and it's that
site where electrodes stimulate the
nerve of the auditory nerve and evoke
auditory percept
or auditory phosphene that you might
want to consider alternative and this
has been shown to be extremely
successful helping many people and not
only communicate one-on-one but also
over the phone so it doesn't depend on
lip-reading or anything so individuals
are able to communicate they probably do
not hear the way we do but it's what's
called functional hearing that is the
ability to at least interact and
communicate and I'll get back to this
notion of functional because what we're
going to be talking about in the context
of motor control is I'll probably
functional motor control not real motor
control in the sense
you know playing the piano or dancing or
riding a bicycle necessarily but
something that allows the individual to
interact and communicate another
neuroprosthetic is the visual prosthetic
based on this notion of a phospide that
is a violet instead of mechanically
touching the eye this is one of the
earliest visual prosthetic developed by
friendly in the 60s and what's pictured
here is an individual a woman who's
blind and doctor Brinley has implanted
electrodes in the back of her head where
the visual cortex is and by applying
electrical current to the back of the
head she experiences these phosphenes
these spots of light and as you can see
behind her is this big rack of
electronics which are delivering the
current to different electrodes and
depending on which electrode you
stimulate you get a spot beam and
different a different spot of space and
so the principle is that if you have
enough of these electrodes stimulated at
the same time you can create an image by
connecting the dots so others have also
tried to develop a cortical visual
prosthetic such such as Dobelle here so
pictured on the top is an individual who
was blind
Dobel was the scientist who implanted
electrodes in the back of his head and
then using a little miniature camera
that resides on the glasses you can
record visual input which then gets
transmitted electrically to the back of
the head and then applying applying
electrical current to the visual cortex
and this showed some limited success at
least the Enabling at least it was
claimed that the individuals could could
avoid obstacles and
you can count the number of digits on
your on your finger
more recently two colleagues of mine me
of toll at the University of Chicago and
Phil Troy get Illinois Institute of
Technology are trying to develop sort of
extend this work developing a cortical
prosthetic by implanting electrodes in
the visual cortex and there they're
doing a clinical trial or they're
beginning a clinical trial right now so
all the brain machine interfaces I've
talked about so far involved applying
electrical signals to the brain that is
providing information to the brain what
I'm talking about here in my research is
the opposite we're going to be recording
and extracting information from the
brain to infer the movement intent of
individuals so what's so what what I
call it is a neuro motor brain machine
interface and this involves a four
components first of all s an electrode
array picture than number one and the
electrode array has 100 tiny electrodes
so there's the electrode array there's
my fingertip to give me a sense of the
scale and the electrode array picks up
electrical signals from individual
neurons which are pictured on the right
here so right here are basically a set
of electrical signals from a bunch of
neurons so each row represents one
electrode and each little tick mark
represents the spiking the the very
brief electrical discharge when a neuron
fires so they're pictured as little tick
marks vertical tick marks so by
recording from a whole group of these
neurons we're hoping to then send that
through number to a decoding algorithm
which interprets these signals
to work to try to infer the intent of
the individuals such as the joint
position theta the joint velocity d
theta/dt or the torque that you want to
or force you want to generate on your
arm
number three we send these decoded
signals to an output device and that
output device can be a prosthetic limb
such as this as pictured here it could
be an autonomous robot they could also
be actually the muscles of the paralyzed
individual by electrically stimulating a
group of muscles so paralyzed
individuals still have intact
functioning muscles as long as they're
rehabilitated properly what's what's
missing is the link between the brain
and the muscles and so by implanting an
array in the motor areas of the brain we
can decode this motor intent and then
send them to a set of electrodes in the
muscles to actually move the muscles and
move the limb finally the fourth
component is sensory feedback now
sensory feedback comes in different
flavors for example vision vision is
critical for guiding our movements but
there's also the sense of kinesthesis
that is we can feel where our limbs are
in space and how they're moving even
when they're our eyes are shut and this
is a critically important sensory
modality or normal motor control we know
this from individuals who are lost their
perfect well they've had damage to their
purple nerves the disorders called
neural arch fiber neuropathy and they
essentially don't touch don't feel touch
or the sense of kinesthesis and they're
severely motor disabled I've actually
worked with some of these individuals
and they are walking with a walker they
have to use their
vision to guide their legs as they walk
so we're gonna talk actually today about
the role of vision and kinesthesis in
the context of a neuro motor brain
machine interface before I get to the
questions we're going to try to answer
these is the this is a better image of
the array that we implant in the brain
so on the top left is the grid of
electrodes that have both of 100
electrodes and it looks like a bed of
nails and essentially that's what it is
except it's made out of silicon it's
tipped with electrode with metal and
it's the tips of those electrodes that
pick up electrical signals we plant this
in motor areas of the brain and what
what's depicted down below is a picture
of a monkey brain and sitting right in
front I'm showing here now two arrays
that are implanted one right here is
implanted in the primary motor cortex
that is the the critical node of the
brain that controls voluntary movement
and it's in the arm area of the primary
motor cortex so it when when an animal
or an individual thinks about moving its
arm cells and neurons in that part of
the brain will start activating and and
firing and we're recording from that
part of the brain I've also showing you
here another array in the so called pre
motor dorsal aspect PMD of premotor
cortex this is an area of the brain that
activates when you first plan to make a
movement the initial planning before you
actually execute the movement and we're
interested in that area as well but
enough focus my attention mainly on m1
primary motor
Thanks and I'm gonna pass this on and
and and I'm going to describe this slide
for a moment and this is actually a
movie so this movie will show you
electrical signals from a whole group of
neurons recorded simultaneously with our
acquisition system these little panel
here represents the action potentials or
the the spiking of individual neurons as
an animal is engaging in the task and
and basically when you're they just
they're very brief events they last
about a millisecond or so long and then
as the movie goes on you'll you'll see a
focus on four different channels where
you'll see kind of like an oscilloscope
trace where you basically see these
these spikes these action potentials
occurring at a longer time scale so they
look like vertical tick marks and you'll
see how they evolve in time so I'll pass
it on now video will play
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so today I'm going to talk about
I'm trying to try to answer two
questions first is how do you build such
a brain machine interface neuromotor
brain machine your face when a patient
can't move because ultimately we're
going to be using such an interface to
help people with tetraplegia
due to spinal cord injury or do you do
to ALS or severe brain stroke the second
question when answer is can kinesthesis
that that sense of feeling where your
limb is in space and how it moves can we
use kinases to augment such a brain
machine interface so getting to the
first question how do you build a brain
machine interface when a patient can't
move the problem is as follows
normally what we do is we try to relate
the brain activity to the motion of the
limbs so we do this with animals and
normally the animal is moving its arm
like playing a video game for example
and we record brain signals as they're
moving their arm to play the video game
and what we do then is relate
mathematically the neural activity which
shown here's our set of numbers the
response group of neurons relate that to
the motion of the limb as they're
playing the video game so let's say the
position of the hand in space and then
we're built what we do is then we build
a mathematical relationship between the
two in this case what I've depicted here
is a linear relationship between those
two
but it could be a non-linear
relationship as well it doesn't really
matter so that works fine when an
individual or an animal can move its
limb but what happens when an individual
can't move I'm so depicted here on the
left is our first patient we actually
under did a clinical trial with such a
neuroma motor prosthetic and this young
man was injured and was left paralyzed
from the neck down and he could think
about moving his limbs but could not
actually move it so we only had only one
half of the equation shown here we had
the responses of neurons the big arm
matrix but we did not have the motion of
the limb the x and y position of the
lemon space let's say so what do we do
well it was actually a thought that my
graduate student came up with he said
what if we show our monkeys the video
game they played but not but just
possibly watched it while while not
engaging in the task perhaps those cells
and motor cortex would still would
activate even while the monkeys
passively watching the idea from for
this stems from earlier findings several
decades ago the phenomenon called mirror
neurons these are neurons that respond
when a monkey makes a movements that
just reaches out and grasps and a raisin
but also when the experimenter does the
same act and the monkey is just watching
and and so I was in a recording in a
certain brain area called the ventral
premotor cortex my graduate students
suggested perhaps in the primary motor
cortex would see such a thing and so we
actually conducted an experiment so this
is what's called mirroring it might be
what underlies imitation behavior so
when you watch someone else engaging in
an action you can't help but again
engaging in the same action so I don't
know if you've experienced this yourself
but I'm an avid tennis player and when I
watched tennis professionals playing on
television I can't help but almost
internally try to make the same weakness
because it's just something so ingrained
in me and so I'm so motivated to do it
that it just internally generate see no
I actually don't engage in the action so
here's how we did this to test this idea
of mirror okay so this video that was
about to be shown shows a cursor a red
cursor that the monkeys controlling with
his joystick they hit a blue target so
you'll watch this video for a moment and
you
okay so now we're gonna engage in an
experiment here where the experimenter
where the monkey engages in two
conditions one is called the action
condition where he plays the video game
video game as normal by moving the
joystick shown on the left and the
action observation condition where he
watches the video game that he just
played so we he's just sitting there
passively watching and he's not allowed
to make movements so he's not restrained
he's the arm is still sitting on the
endoskeletal robot with his hand on the
joystick and he's free to move if he
wanted to but we trained him not to make
movements and the way we do that is that
if he makes a movement accidentally we
shut off the video screen and he won't
receive any applesauce or juice or
reward so he's motivated to not make a
movement so he's watching this action
that he just played he just did a few
minutes previously so this just shows
you sort of bird's eye view of the
monkey on the Left where he's moving the
cursor by moving the joystick to hit
targets and in blue you see the motion
basically the path of that but the
joystick and the cursor made over many
many trials of this task so basically
he's scribbling he's moving all
throughout the workspace hitting
different targets I'm not showing you
the targets just the motion of the
joystick and cursor and then red it
shows you what the motion of his arm is
while he's watching in the action
observation condition and as you might
see there are some slight movements he's
actually given a little bit of
wiggle room so he doesn't have to be
perfectly still but if you look on the
right display right panel what's
happening is the blue is what he's doing
when he's playing the game the red is
when he's watching the game and what you
might notice is he's basically staying
still and occasionally they'll make a
little twitch and and presumably that
might be because he's trying to readjust
himself in the chair or whatnot he just
and anyway but basically for most for
most of the experiment in the in this
condition he's not making any movements
of his arm okay so here are the we're
recording from primary motor cortex and
what I would have expected is this is is
shown on the left so the left is the
example that I would have predicted in
motor cortex so what is shown here is
the response measured as the firing rate
the number of action potentials or
firings of a given neuron per unit time
as a function of time on the x-axis so
zero is when a new target appears and
the monkey has to make a movement to
that new target the blue is showing you
the firing rate of the neuron when he's
playing the game and the yellow is when
he's watching the game and as you as you
can see when he's watching the game the
neuron isn't firing at all it isn't
changing its firing rate it's just
staying at some baseline firing rate
whereas in blue it's actually increasing
but much to my surprise the other two
panels middle and the right show you
cells that fire almost in the exact same
way when he played when he when he
played the game and when he watched it
so the blue and the yellow profiles are
nearly identical and in some cases we
saw even stronger responses when he
watched the game than when he played the
game so this was paint came to was quite
a surprise to me
but given that we saw this and we saw
this in quite a number of neurons we
said well perhaps we can use this
phenomenon of mirror-like responses to
build a decoder so the idea is we now
show the animal or show the human
subject an action on a screen so it's us
it's for example a cursor moving to a
target and by showing this the cells in
the motor cortex will fire
we then relate mathematically the firing
of the neurons to the motion of the
cursor he's watching we thus build such
a decoding algorithm and then give it to
the human or the animal to to use to
voluntarily move the cursor and so
that's what we did in our brain gate
pilot trial this was a FDA approved
pilot trial where we implanted for
individuals with tetraplegia ALS or Lou
Gehrig's disease
and a brain stem stroke and we use that
approach mirroring to build devices bell
beats decoding algorithms and I just
want to show you a short video of our
patient number one in terms of allegic
controlling a cursor to hit various
applications on computer
the following video clips show an actual
clinical study participant using the
brain gate system to check his email
change the channels of a television and
use a personal computer won't open the
first email which says congrats it says
you are doing that great job next I'm
going to open the second email which
states hi there it says hi we'll talk so
I'm going to the exit next one turn on
my television I want to hit the power
button to turn television on the
television is launched I'm going to
channel down there's Gerald Arlene I'm
going to channel up
okay so you may have noticed this
individual was able to voluntarily
control this cursor to use his mail
email application the TV controller and
the way he controlled this was by
activating by thinking about moving the
cursor to hit these targets and you may
have noticed the way he activated these
icons on the screen was by moving the
cursor over just over the icon and then
all of a sudden it would click so
clicking is something we is also
important because we don't want these
individuals to hit and to activate
certain applications if they don't
intend to if you may have noticed in the
video that he accidentally went through
certain icons which he didn't want to go
through and that's not something you'd
want to do if he's like controlling a
mobile wheelchair robotic wheelchair
that and so obviously something you
really want to be sure that the
individual wants to activate the
application so we've actually developed
algorithms that can decode click as well
and the way we did that was by having
the heat subjects think about grasping
an object and as soon as he thought
about grasping the click would occur so
he had both control of the cursor in 2d
space as well as click control by
thinking of grasping
okay so I've told you one solution to
this problem of developing a decoding
algorithm for people who can't move
another solution is actually kind of
silly but it actually works just trial
and error that is give an individual an
arbitrary mapping between brain control
brain neurons neurons and motion of a
device such as a robot and through lots
of practice these individuals can learn
to activate the right set of neurons in
the right way
to voluntarily control the device
properly and actually that trial and
error learning in fact does work and I'm
going to show you this now in a an
example monkey who was controlling a
robotic device now these monkeys we
found with amputation so we actually
they had undergone therapeutic education
to rescue them because they get into
fights and to rescue them they had to to
save them they had to amputate their
arms and so we got a hold of these from
a vendor and they had been amputated ten
years previously and so the we implanted
the motor cortex of these individuals
one piece either on the side of the
brain control lateral to the amputation
that is the side of the brain that would
normally have control the intact lemon
had been there but it was missing or on
the ipsilateral side on the side that
controls the arm that's intact and we
wanted to look at how the and use a
completely arbitrary mapping decoding
algorithm and wanted to see whether the
monkeys could learn over time to control
a robotic device so basically they're
using an arbitrary decoding algorithm to
control this robot this robot has an arm
as well as a hand and the job of the
monkey is to reach out with a robot
reach out in front of it grasp an object
which would be a basically a sphere
grasp it pull it back and then release
it and that would be a successful trial
so I just and and the way we
did this implemented this was by
assigning arbitrarily a set of neurons
to either control the reaching component
that is moving the robot forward or back
and another signing another group of
neurons the green neurons to encode
grasped to open and close the hand and
so these were distinct groups of neurons
or neural clusters sitting on the array
so you can see in the array right there
the 10 by 10 array and we just
arbitrarily signed ten neurons or
roughly ten neurons to each cluster
there's the array with a ten green
neurons controlling roughly ten neuron
controlling to grasp and another group
of neurons controlling to reach so I'm
going to show you now a video of our one
of our monkeys our contralateral monkey
that is a monkey with an array implanted
contralateral to the annotation that had
learned to control the robot to grasp an
object after about 40 days of practice
so here's the video
you
okay so this shows you an example of the
learning that takes place over those 30
to 40 days so I'm showing you now the
contralateral monkey and the ipsilateral
that is one monkey with an array
implanted under lateral to the
annotation and the other 1 EPSA
laterally amputation the top two panels
show you early of an exposure to the
device and as you can see what's plotted
there is the grasp aperture on the
y-axis and the reach position the job of
the animal of course is to coordinate
the two to reach forward and grasp
appropriately and you can see in the
early trials they're basically
uncoordinated and moving all over the
place in that in this two-dimensional
space but late in learning you see a
much more coordinated and less variable
trajectory where the animal reaches
forward opens its grasp and then closes
down on the object and a with a variety
of different measures including the time
it took an animal to reach to
successfully accomplish the trial
behavior performance improves so in
these two monkeys the blue and the
yellow the time the target decreases
dramatically and in some cases
approaches around one successful trial
every half minute or so so one of the
goals of this work besides trying to
help individuals with severe motor
disabilities to enable them to control
devices is to look at how the brain
might reorganize with long-term exposure
of such a brain machine interface so we
wanted to examine functional
connectivity in these experiments with
moles controlling the robot and we
wanted to look at connectivity
functional connectivity within a neural
cluster that would control the reach
within the grasp as well as connectivity
between the reach and the grasp clusters
and the way we did this was using a
statistical technique called Granger
causality and I won't go into all the
math about it but essentially what it's
trying to do is trying to find a
statistical relationship between the
present response of one neuron given the
past response of another neuron so take
for example here in this display we have
now a group of neurons shown is
basically action potentials the spiking
these vertical tick marks as a function
of time and let's say we want to predict
the response of neuron x1 well we can
use at the present at time t naught we
can use the past responses of that
neuron to predict its future response
and that does actually remarkably well
but but what if we use the past
responses of other neurons
for example neuron x2 measured at a time
in the past to predict the current
firing of neuron x1 if we can more
reliably predict neuron x ones response
it at the present based on the past
response of x2 then we say x 2.is
granger granger causes x1 and it's based
on the very simple intuition that you
know if if it's cloudy today or cloudy
now and it rains in 30 minutes
one might be able to speculate the
clouds cause the rain in some sense so
that's the basic intuition and from that
we can then create these functional map
works connectivity networks or one
neuron is connected to another based on
whether it can predict the future
responses of the other neuron so if you
look at the contralateral monkey early
in exposure the connectivity is very
sparse so what's plotted here as a
circle is basically all the neurons that
are controlling the reach in the grasp
control of the robot so basically all
these all these points around the circle
or different neurons and the line
segments connecting them are the
functional connections measured with
this Granger causal measurement we see a
very sparse connectivity early and
exposure that then builds up over time
and expands dramatically over the 40
days of exposure so here as well as
latent exposure a very dense connection
so so right here so that's over 30 to 40
days of exposure a very dense connection
matrix now in the ipsilateral monkey me
saw something quite different so this is
the monkey that was whose array was
implanted on the side on the same side
as the application so that is the site
of the brain that controls the other
limb on the other side that's intact
here we saw a very different picture of
connectivity early an exposure you see a
very strong connection network connected
network among all the neurons
controlling the robot and this might not
be surprising given this this group of
neurons is controlling an intact limb or
has been over you know the past ten
years but then what we see is
over time the network actually proves
itself reduces connectivity before
finally developing a very dense
connection network after long-term
exposure so I think that's kind of an
interesting but not finding that we see
changes in this functional connectivity
that might actually be mediated by real
synaptic connection changes with long
term brain machine interfaces so you're
actually literally changing the brain
with long term brain machine interface
exposure ok so I'm going on
finish up really quickly here I want to
briefly mention try to answer the second
question is how do we ought meant a
brain machine interface with a sense of
penis thesis now the approach we're
going to take here is by using the
native limb as a or the native arm and
this is in the case of people that are
tetraplegic do do spinal cord injury or
ALS so this wouldn't apply education so
if they have residual sensation in their
arm which in many cases is true we can
use that residual sensation of
proprioception to help them guide the
brain machine interface so this is how
it works and we did an experiment we had
an implant implanted in the primary
motor cortex of a monkey so shown there
there's their implant right there
we then sent those signals to a
real-time decoder so a decoding
algorithm that decoded signal signals in
real time so I had to work very fast we
then sent that real-time decoder output
to a cursor that the monkey was
controlling with brain and so he's
moving the cursor to hit a target just
like in the earlier experiments I show
and any so it doesn't depend on his arm
his arm is actually sitting underneath
the screen and his hand is on a joystick
but it's a it's irrelevant what his arm
is actually doing in fact he's trained
not to move his arm so simultaneously we
sent this real-time decoder output to
the robot controller that controls the
exoskeleton
remember the monkey's arm is sitting on
a two linked exoskeletal robot so
there's the robot controller the
exoskeleton is basically what his arm is
resting on and we sent that decoded
output to control to actually physically
move the arm to follow the cursor okay
so we first built a decoding algorithm
using the visual playback paradigm that
I talked about earlier in my talk so the
monkeys basically watching the cursor
move to hit the targets and he's just
sitting still and we build the algorithm
then in the and the real-time decoding
the RTD conditions we actually the
monkeys now using the decoder to move
the cursor volitionally so he's moving
the cursor by activating his motor
cortex in the first condition called a
visible RTD his arm is still and he's
just his job is to move the cursor to
hit the target in the vision plus
proprioception or kinesthesia RVT he's
moving the cursor to hit the target but
at the same time the decoded algorithm
is moving his arm to follow the cursor
and then finally in this third condition
which I really want to talk much about
but basically that could they aside from
saying that in this condition the arm is
moving in a way that's not correlated
with the motion of the cursor so here
the results I'm just going to show you
the top panels here the time to target
that is how much time it took the monkey
to hit the targets a low number is good
so the blue bar represents the time it
took him to hit the target when he's
actually playing the game with his arm
just normal the video game playing the
yellow is when he's using the real-time
decoder to move the cursor with his
brain but his arm is sitting still and
then of course the time of targets the
red is now when we incorporate this
proprioception of kinesthesis by moving
the arm to follow the cursor and that
results in much better performance the
time to target decreases and the gray is
that fourth condition they had a random
condition so basically both monkeys
monkey m'kay and monkey be the addition
of this kinesthesis shown in the red
bars leads to better faster performance
in the task and we're doing the same
thing now or recently we did the same
thing with a hand exoskeleton so doing
the same kind of experiment where we're
driving the hand the digits the index
finger and thumb with an exoskeleton the
scene whether the addition of
kinesthesis that occurs by passively
moving the digits will enable the animal
to control the brain machine interface
more effectively and finally the the
approach I've just talked about works if
you have residual feedback sensory that
is proprioception or kinesthesis but
what happens if you're a completely
paralyzed individual with no sensation
in that case the approach will we are
hoping to take in the near future is to
implant an array similar to the array
that we were implanted in the motor
cortex but implanted in the
somatosensory cortex shown in green here
the area that was and had neurons that
respond to talk
and proprioception murkiness thesis and
by electrically stimulating that part of
the brain we could create artificial
percept of motion of the limb and that
would then by then using a robotic
device such as the robot I showed you
that has tactile and proprioceptive
sensors we can send that signal little
signals back and electrically stimulate
the somatosensory cortex so that's the
approach we're going to take in the
future and finally I'd like to thank my
lab members in particular cars right
here on the left
Karthikeyan Subramanian erin sieminski
matt best thank you very much thank you
so much for your presentation dr. hats
appleís we want to get to the audience
questions and input so here's a reminder
as how to how to communicate with us
questions can be submitted you have a
Q&A button at the lower left we will try
to get to all of you but if not we will
be sure to follow up after the broadcast
so here's our very first question dr.
haataja is how long do these cortical
implants last so they will that's a very
good question because it it's highly
variable and in some cases they last for
several months in other cases in our
best case have lasted for nine years and
this is an important question because if
this is going to work in a clinically
viable system that help people with
tetraplegia or ALS or imputation we want
a device that can last for at least you
know multiple years so that you don't
have to go back in and explain
a new device and so the answer is that
it's highly variable and that's a it's
an issue an issue that has to be
addressed in the future another audience
member would like to know what are the
major challenges before such a system
can help patients with tetraplegia or
ALS well that actually follows from the
first question which basically the if we
can address this technical or
engineering problem that is create a
device a chip that is implanted in the
brain that can last consistently and
reliably for many years ideally five
years or longer that would be that's one
challenge that means if you addressed
and you know the question there is where
where these why is it not always
reliable is it because the device is non
manufactured aspects and it sometimes
breaks or is their biological sort of
foreign body reaction that the that
occurs that because it's a foreign body
that's implanted in the brain
the immune system the glial cells will
react to that and encapsulate the device
in some cases resulting in poor
recording quality and then the second
major challenge I think is it's more
it's more commercial really how exactly
will such a device be developed will it
be done in the private sector or in the
public sector we tried to do this in the
private sector by creating a
their company and realize that the
amount of money required to develop such
a system is very high and and the time
required is long and and unfortunately
the network patience is rather limited
so all of those things come together and
make it very challenging to do this
privately so it would probably require a
joint arrangement with perhaps the
government to help individuals such as
soldiers coming back from Iraq and
Afghanistan with amputation as well as
helping civilians with these disorders
and so some sort of partnership where
the government might we have a lot of
wonderful questions coming in but we
just have time for one more
doctor hat sample is how many neurons do
you need to record from that depends on
what your goal is if for the very simple
two dimensional control I showed you
moving the cursor in 2d we can do that
quite well with maybe a couple of dozen
of neurons so 2013 Iran the same is true
for the robot that I showed you the
robot had two degrees of freedom that it
could is it can either reach forward and
back or it could open and close its hand
again very limited and there we use a
roughly ten neurons for each control is
so totally twenty neurons as you
increase the challenge that is making
you you have to you make the problem
more difficult than just controlling a
multi degree of freedom robot in a very
flexible way you'll
we need more neurons the other thing on
the other hand that comes that might
help us is the idea of learning I
already showed you how monkeys can learn
to control the device so perhaps
learning might help us overcome some of
the challenges because right now we
can't report from know millions of
neurons in our best case we can we can
record from about 200 neurons
simultaneously so there's going to be
some upper limit although people are
developing technologies in the future
but right now we're limited to roughly a
hundred neurons so perhaps learning
could help us dr. haataja list thank you
so much for a wonderful presentation do
you have any last final comments you'd
like to share with the audience I guess
my final thought is that if this kind of
work is interesting to students you
don't have to have a specific set of
skill set I actually came from a very
diverse background I didn't I was not an
engineer nor was i neuroscientists
initially and sort of went sort of
accidentally I got into this field and
my past experience in education helped
me I'm doing right now
so anybody's interested in this kind of
work use your past education and
experience that helped you move forward
you could always shift
years wherever you are whether you're in
college or graduate school or even as a
postdoc I made a switch and even as a
postdoc I
I made a pretty dramatic shift in my
research direction so it's never too
late to switch thank you again sir and
we just want to remind audience members
that if you weren't able to speak
directly with you today we'll be sure to
follow up with you thank you for taking
part we want to thank today's presenters
as well as you for joining us here at
lab roots comm the leading scientific
social networking site for more
information visit us at lab roots com
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing on our website through
June 16th 2017 we will let you know when
it's been posted and we hope you pass
the information on to your colleagues
who couldn't take part in today's
broadcast have a great day goodbye